so in the midst of sort of general
concerns that the Trump team is
completely unprepared to be taking
control of the United States listen to
the list of problems that we now know
the Trump transition team is having
number one it is total and utter chaos
within the Trump and transition team
after the removal of chris christie and
the replacement of chris christie with
mike pens to actually run the transition
team itself and you might hope well that
decision was probably made for some
reason that would make the transition
team run more effectively but lo and
behold no the Obama administration
notified the press that they had not yet
received a memo from Mike Pence which
allows the Obama administration and the
incoming a president elect Trump
administration's to start formally
discussing how to hand off the
government that sort of a big deal you
sort of need to figure that out and have
limited time to do it this signed paper
did eventually show up hours late and
the weird thing is it was the same
document that chris Christie had
previously signed when he was heading up
the transition team so it raises the
question of if the document wasn't
changed why couldn't the Trump team just
get Mike Pence to sign this piece of
paper and get it over to the Obama
administration Trump transition team
officials just didn't show up at the
Pentagon for discussions about that
transition Trump officials just didn't
show up at the Department of Energy
which by the way is responsible for
keeping those nuclear codes that we are
all really really scared about Trump
having anything to do with and no
business having anything to do with
those Trump's team officials just didn't
show up when the Department of Energy
was expecting them on Monday no one at
the Justice Department has heard from
the Trump team and the question is what
is causing all of this lack of
organization is part of it but another
element of the root cause is that the
Trump transition team and this is insane
who wouldn't want to be a part of a
presidential administration the Trump
team is having a difficult time finding
able-minded Republicans that are even
willing to work with them and Red Alert
a Democratic sore
verse who like others would only discuss
what's going on on the condition of
anonymity said that transition officials
have been informally asking Obama
appointees to recommend Republicans to
take over their jobs this is so pathetic
guys they no call no show and then they
don't know who to hire hey Obama
administration could you recommend some
Republicans to us so that we can maybe
get this thing moving what's pretty
funny how chris Christie was in charge
of the transition team when the prospect
of a Donald Trump presidency was just
wishful thinking yeah and now that it's
become a reality Mike Pence is in charge
and Rachel I mean when we think about
this you've got all of these Republicans
everywhere who seem desperate to have
positions of power all of a sudden now
none of them are jumping at the
opportunity to work in the Trump
administration but I also feel like
because Trump doesn't have a lot of
experience he doesn't have this long
list of officials from the bush-era to
tap from so where is he looking to yet
well he was going to put the best people
around him and apparently he can't even
put people around him who can then find
people to put around him and we're
getting bit several levels removed here
from Trump being the really great
manager that he says he's going to be
and very telling is that Elliot Cohen
who was a long time neo conservative
voice he tweeted about the total chaos
and disorder that's going on within the
Trump transition team we're gonna put
that tweet up for you saying after
exchange with Trump transition team
changed my recommendation stay away
they're angry arrogant screaming you
lost will be ugly and then in the midst
of this you have rinse Priebus according
to sources who is going to be the White
House chief of staff leaving his role as
RNC chair he is now very concerned about
the possibility of corey lewandowski
former trump campaign manager and and
CNN contributor corey lewandowski may be
named RNC chair and rinse Priebus is
very concerned about that the
Republicans are scared of what the
Republicans under Trump are going to do
I understand that but kind of going back
to the unraveling I'm wondering if the
catalyst for this was giving so much
power to jared kushner and saying oh
can make decisions kind of based on
emotions and saying I'm going to dismiss
Rodgers because uh when Chris Christie
was an a federal prosecutor he put my
father in jail or saying uh that Rogers
agreed with Obama and saying that he had
a he didn't mislead the public in terms
of Benghazi and that's starkly contrast
with Trump's narrative about Benghazi so
let's just dismiss him yeah well jared
kushner of course Trump son-in-law who
by all indications has a very very uh
has very significant influence pad over
Donald Trump and it's unclear exactly
what his role is going to be in the
administration we haven't really heard
much about it I warned you Trump is not
qualified to run the country we've been
saying it for a while he likes the hunt
of it he likes the competition he wants
the power he sees associated with it but
now that he's won it's abundantly clear
he's not interested in governing and we
really don't know which sectors of the
Republican Party is going to be in
charge because there's the alt right
group like Steven Steven Bannon yeah and
then there's the more establishment
types like Ryan's previous we don't know
who's gonna go and we're hearing about
Giuliani a newt gingrich and some well
yeah but Giuliani says it's all fine
because this happened with Reagan and
Clinton so if this is normal yeah I
trust me Giuliani inherently especially
after he told us the FBI was leaking him
information or at least implied it